Allen found four marbles to add to his
five marbles currently in his pocket he
then had a competition with his friends
and tripled his marbles write a
numerical expression to model the
situation without performing any
operations so let's think about what's
going on so he already had five marbles
in his pocket so he already had five
marbles in his pocket and then he found
four more marbles to add to that so we
can add the four marbles to the five
marbles so four marbles plus the five
marbles so that's what happens after the
first sentence he he found four marbles
to add to his five marbles currently in
his pocket he then had a competition
with his friends and tripled his marbles
so this is how many marbles he had
before tripling and now he's tripling
now he's tripling his marbles so we'd
want to multiply three times the total
number of marbles he has now times four
plus five so this right over here is the
numerical expression that models the
situation without any without performing
any operations we of course could then
actually calculate this he now has he
has nine marbles before tripling and
then you multiply it by three and he is
27 but this is what they're asking for
they want us they want us to write this
expression